angry frustrated and helpless these
people say the government is not
listening
thousands of workers from the state and
private sectors held demonstrations in
Colombo on Wednesday
among them doctors Engineers port and
oil refinery workers and bankers
they say unfair taxes have pushed them
to the brink taxation is a part of a
civilized society we have to pay taxes
and we have been paying our taxes
throughout the time so the problem is
when you bring up a tax policy
it should it should reflect what is the
intentions and what will be the outcome
of the tax the collected money should be
spended wisely to the better amount of
society but we cannot see such things
are happening mismanagement corruption
the pandemic that followed devastating
bomb attacks in 2019 and unsustainable
debt have pushed Sri Lanka into an
economic tail spin
in the year up to August 2022 the rupee
lost nearly 45 of its value
public anger over shortages of Basics
and long cues for goods and services
resulted in the resignation of president
gotabe rajapaksa in July last year his
prime minister and now President Ronald
Vikram singer delivered his policy
speech at the reopening of parliament on
Wednesday
he stressed the need for economic
reforms the government's briefs should
be to direct the private sector towards
business and stay in the background the
government should only get involved in
regulate reactivity public amenities and
maintaining Law and Order vikrama singer
said he is ready to take unpopular
decisions for the benefit of the country
he listed changes to laws and
regulations and told the house that if
people could endure the hardships for
another five to six months a solution
could soon be found
but on the streets protesters dismiss
his promises as fairy tales
that's a description vikrama singha used
to describe Pleasures made by those he
said were obstructing the country
towards poverty
people expecting any sign of relief in
President Ronald vikrama saying his
policy address were disappointed he
repeated calls for people to endure
austerity and cut back but many are
angry and say they're struggling to
survive amid High inflation tax
increases and high interest rates Manila
Fernandez Al Jazeera Colombo